good morning believe nation today's
message is I'll work your opponent all
right okay yeah how does it go oh my god
can we do it one more time I can do it
good morning believe nation today's
message is at work your opponent over to
you Carli Lloyd best piece of advice
I've ever gotten is probably
to train and out work your opponent's
focus on yourself compete against
yourself and just give a hundred percent
every single day you got to practice on
your own you got to spend ample amount
of minutes time whether it's juggling
whether it's shooting you've got to just
put in the extra work and I think that
if you do that in life and in anything
that you aspire to be great at you're on
the right track so what do you think I'm
a strong believer in that so when I
started salsa six and a half years ago I
was not a great dancer i repeated level
one twice and I actually at the end of
the first time I did level one at the
end of every class I would go to the
park where I lived and by myself
practice over and over and I remember I
had a bunch of like old grandmother's
who were you know babysitting their
grandkids um watching me and they were
you know talking and laughing or
whatever but I was just kept practicing
my basics over and over this line rings
in my mind hard work beats talent when
talent doesn't work hard now in salsa
and many other things I did I wasn't
naturally talented I had to work hard
and that's what I did and I I'm a strong
believer that you know when your
opponent sleeping you know when your
opponent's having a cup of coffee when
they're watching netflix you should be
working if you want to succeed so you
should be out performing them through
hard work where I excel is ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guys sleeping I'm working what
other guys eaten I'm working yeah I
totally agree i resonate with the
message to I think when I look at my
youtube channel as an example you guys
can go back a lot of you have started
going back to my older videos and say
what a big change has happened because
the content was still good but the
delivery sucked i was nervous and I was
boring and I didn't have any energy and
it's a big difference compared to where
I am now and it just came from making
we've three thousand-plus videos on the
channel like you hopefully will get
better after doing something three
thousand times and I think the key is
finding something that you love so much
that you don't mind putting in the work
in the air because you have to force
yourself to do it like when you wanted
to do salsa wasn't like I'm forcing
myself to get better at salsa like you'd
like to do it it made you come alive
same
hang with me in the YouTube channel and
with me and salsa too like I wanted the
practice I was sitting there in meetings
for my business and sitting across from
a guy and I'm just imagining turn
patterns and I'm thinking if I took his
hand and put it over my head and then
took his shoulder and twisted him what
kind of combination and I've missed like
10 minutes of what we're actually
talking about because I was daydreaming
about salsa like that's what you want to
find and when you find that thing that
you love so much it's easier to put in
the work with to force yourself and it's
harder to actually get it done so the
question today today is what are your
thoughts on talent and working hard
count versus working hard leave it in
the comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso